so yeah it's Saturday got a new light
yes as you can see we're still playing
around it but it's like we wanted
something a little more mysterious and
Atmospheric yeah I bought this DMX right
here cheap Chinese cheap Chinese DMX and
I got daisy chain these lights
eventually and learn how to program it
right now he's got a concept caveman
style we're just gonna individually
program that it's on down it's on damn
extension cords yeah but I got all the
DMX cables and everything all daisy
chain them on there and program and yeah
okay I'll be able to get something
better than that going to get this
that's pretty cool the opposite I mean
honestly we've experimented with all the
different lights because we just got
these lights today yeah that's one of
the reasons why it's two whites I'm
putting this up later than usual because
we've been like farting around with that
trying to get it really seems like you
know it has all colors but it seems like
blue really looks the best yeah it's
because our walls are kind of blueish
grey it's great so if you put any other
color on it just looks white yeah cuz I
was like oh let's have red and stuff but
it's like the red looks okay but the
blue look is by far looks the nicest
green just ends up looking white and
gold looked white gold look white yeah
at least on that color background yeah
but well it looks a little more
interesting than it used to look
yeah and eventually like I said we'll
still we only literally just got these
lights like a couple hours ago and we've
been playing with them to see like what
looks good
so you know this we're just like
experimenting and trying it out that
worked out yeah let's see so it's
Saturday I actually recorded an episode
of the show last night and it's the long
one yeah drunk and he like starts waving
around the chair and late
complain about [ __ ] invisible [ __ ]
rin-chan out when I started hitting
[ __ ] Howard two-and-a-half I'm
usually pretty [ __ ] loaded so we're
talking about these cases and stomping
these girls to death you know that goth
girl to death you know those kids did
that in England I was [ __ ] pissed and
yes our friend Mouse was spinning live
so I put her on and she was waving but
she missed it turned around I was like
[ __ ] stop she stopped you get selfie
yeah yeah she was like she was doing
because obviously DJ isn't [ __ ] like
that can't do it Kings is so they're
just doing like [ __ ] from their houses
yeah their base I could drink it I was
like a bastard yeah yeah and it's like
[ __ ] man it's like I I only had two and
I think I drank I'm slower than usual
but it's like that well I had to wake up
at 6:00 this morning and throw up a
little bit I don't think that was
because of the amount of liquor though I
think it was because it was cranberry
juice yeah it's good for liver yeah it's
good for your bladder also yeah so they
say
and also because we had spaghetti
meatball so it was like kind of like a
lot of acid acids like in there the same
so I kind of woke up this morning I was
like yeah but the nice thing though is
that I actually ended up going back to
sleep and I slept till 11 o'clock I
haven't I don't remember the last time I
did that I was like I must have [ __ ]
needed it and it helps because it was
like storming this morning so it was
like really dark cuz I woke up and I was
like oh maybe it's must be still early
so - Lee poor little Pookie was because
it was thundering like really bad like
at first I don't even know it was
thunder I'm like is that the garbage
truck in the garbage day what the [ __ ]
is that noise but it's like yeah that it
was like it was [ __ ] Thunder and [ __ ]
and poor little Pookie was sleeping next
me on the bed she just like set up like
that like yeah yeah it stayed dark
forever yeah she was like looking around
oh my what is that and I kept going it's
okay it's okay and she was just like
over there shakin her little ears were
shaking and stuff I turn around it looks
better back there
it does on the screen looks like a club
when you look back you should go back
there and likes women yeah but so what
else is built like I said not else not a
lot else going on today because we
didn't get up until 11 and then we were
just like sitting around having coffee
and I've been editing the show and the
show is so [ __ ] long we had to record
it in like eight separate segments and
so I'd like piece of bone back together
like take out [ __ ] where I forgot where
I my place and everything like that sits
I'm still not done with it I'm doing the
audio now but yeah it'll be done see
what selling point what else is going on
anything going on in the world not much
it's uh you know not not that I know if
like I said I haven't really had time to
look up anything because I've been like
[ __ ] I'm just watching the news man
starting to come out I [ __ ] called
this [ __ ] Nostradamus [ __ ] always
calls this [ __ ] now they're starting to
say yeah maybe that was something that
came out of that damn Laboratory well
maybe that was an accident that God
maybe that was on per unit minute just
I'll give you [ __ ] next month
actually last first start I said that
[ __ ] what six months ago when I first
came on no first about three months ago
when it first broke out over there think
about two months ago yeah I think it was
late twosome Lady Sarah yeah give you
[ __ ] next month's for the news today
man you saw next but yeah that'll
that'll be your tagline we're gonna make
a shirt like that we yeah we definitely
ought to oh that reminds me to that I
said this on the Regular Show
but since the regular show isn't going
up till Monday or Tuesday hold on what
where I forget you oh you'll remember I
don't know I was talking about me
getting a shirt right and I've thought
man I'd have I'd be walk around with
shirt with my
I'll phone the sheriff and [ __ ] it my
friend my re buddy [ __ ] chief II know
Miguel chief he knows from from from
Cali we were up in Korea together every
shirt he had had a picture of himself on
it okay because back in back in the 90s
that was the [ __ ] is serious technology
you don't remember that picture they put
well he had been taking pictures of him
[ __ ] himself in shirts of pictures of
himself for any generation yeah he
walked by one time and he had a he had a
picture of himself on his shirt and in
that picture he had himself wearing a
shirt yeah yeah yeah sure he goes and
check this out man I in that picture I
had another picture because he has so
many of them damn thing and my mind was
[ __ ] blowing I was trying to and I
said you planned that [ __ ] know just
happen Miguel was [ __ ] funny man
it just happened man man just happens
because he has so many of them it didn't
right he had been taking pictures of
himself with the shirts that he made
right taking pictures of himself what
the booze at the mall yeah well he has
so many of them every time he make a new
and he was wearing a shirt that have him
with one of those shirts on yeah and in
that shirt there was another it's just
kind of like that really early cat meme
which is like at recursions like yeah
like a cat like sitting next yeah screen
like with the picture of the same cat on
it and like and people kept going like
that levels out you plan that [ __ ] yeah
that you counteracts it it just happened
I said oh you plan that [ __ ] Safina
me amigo
on Instagram at you remember there used
to be when I was a kid because in the
80s or maybe early 90s we had a shirt if
we had a store in our mall to where it
should all it was was just like racks of
iron-ons
yeah and you just went in there and you
picked whatever color shirt you run then
they iron on and they did airbrushing
too right well that's where he was
getting them yeah but they also had the
technology to do a quick snapshot yeah
you and put it on that ah yeah well he
had been doing that over and over again
with those funky shirts on with him
wearing the damn shirt yeah cuz I
remember a long time ago when I was like
in the 80s my mom yeah for my birthday
one year she had one made that had Simon
Lebon from Duran Duran on it yeah it
said I love Simon Lebon in the back yeah
and it was like cranberry colored shirt
it was awesome Chicano man get out of me
today he's missing his family too so he
always had like he had the shirts doing
pictures of like his sister's baby mom
with the baby sister and like a grandma
grandma with the mom and the baby and
the sister that's on his shirt and [ __ ]
you know he it's it's a Chicano thing
the whole [ __ ] family's gotta be on
your show okay well then you gotta be on
your shirt wearing a shirt with you on
your shirt on your shirt on your shirt
okay now we get that's I it was good
baby that's it that could be the next 13
o'clock shirt we do is like we'll have a
picture a picture of ourselves with
shirts on it have pictures of ourselves
and then we'll just like just keep those
possible it's just look at it like yeah
now it's like now I'm kind of like I
think they probably get him on a show
explaining that I might still have a
picture of that yeah cuz he was taking
pictures of himself sure it's just like
and he sweared that it was just it just
happened that yeah well that's that's
really funny that he has like t-shirts
with like [ __ ] was 1990 it well you know
I can see how everyone got really
excited about it because in a picture
whatever you
yes sir and you know Chicago is a
[ __ ] real family-oriented you know
and he was in Korea you know so he was
and he missed it
yeah that [ __ ] at a theis you know the
[ __ ] TX yeah where they could make a
shirt for you to you know man and so he
was getting pictures of his family put
on his shirt makes it like because one
of the drunkest [ __ ] with pictures of
his baby sisters are my favorite when I
was a kid was my mom took a picture of
me when I was four that my little baby
brother Eric was just born in 1976 and I
loved that little kid she's like I was
like I used to like wag him around with
me all the time because he was like a
cool little baby and there's like a
really cute picture of me like sitting
in my um in my like yellow what the [ __ ]
are those things from the 70s [ __ ]
bean bags
beanbag chair send in a beanbag chair
like holding my little bit like looking
down and I'm like my favorite picture
but no it's like what I was going to say
like before you yeah but yeah well it
was a good thing that you like still
talked about t-shirts because it does
have something to do with the t-shirt we
set this on the regular episode but
since that's not going up until Monday
or Tuesday I wanted to give a shout out
to Jason because he had just sent us
like yesterday he just sent us PayPal
donation and he was like teasing us
about hey Tom where's my shirt and stuff
like that and so I was saying like we
haven't made any shirts recently because
we don't you know we supplies clothes
down yeah we don't have like a we don't
even have any shirts to print on do we I
got I have one I got so I got a bunch of
shirts but they're all mediums oh yeah
remember that I have one a small but
it's a but it's a women's shirt it's
like it's like a v-neck women's sure I
think I have one but that's all they ran
a store one time and I said I'm gonna
stock up for shirts for myself yeah but
then I never got around a print and on
yeah so they're all just mediums yeah
you know but we need men's and women's
we need a whole supply no I need an
order of everybody and yeah I need the
really some people you know like Rob you
know I got a chat with Rob yeah and I
don't you
Robb's given us so many damn movies yeah
yeah you know I told him I'd hook up his
girlfriend to give me a damn baby doll
shirts yeah said make your titties look
big
yeah give me some make her wear a couple
[ __ ] battleships I turned it to wear
them on the show because it well look
more distracting than actually we get
all kinds of pasties on a corset
[Laughter]
just pretend like a dump [ __ ] I guess
nothing you just moving around like that
is one slapping over this way every time
let's change I'm gonna make that kind of
suggestion that might be close to
pimping you out I'm going to do that
you're not gonna yeah I have to say that
like that would probably be a win
because it wouldn't really matter like
what we even said on this you know
because no boy so what is just nothing
out there cuz I understand focus on the
[ __ ] show talking [ __ ] yeah I'm in a
good mood now if I could say all kinds
of crazy [ __ ] he does well because
sometimes you there's not really like
any kind of you just kind of like say
things that really thinking about it
sometimes just for you yeah yeah it's
like [ __ ] Deacon blues you know no
man [ __ ] Stevie dance on it you know
drink scotch whiskey Oh God behind the
wheel well don't you wanna
for the win I recommend a song if you
guys it's ultimate lounge lizard your
song Deacon blues yeah there's something
there's something just very relaxing
about being down leaves your suit man
put a [ __ ] medallion listen to that
[ __ ]
you need a leisure suit yeah [ __ ]
pastel-colored - my dad had one it was
it how it or blue yeah let's go get like
a powder-blue suit dad no tie just [ __ ]
I gotta grow my chest area yeah you'd
have to go chest hair or really you just
like you know stick it on there and yes
baby is there like yeah like a little
mat so we're gonna wrap up like I said
sorry it's a took us a bit longer to get
around to this but we were farting out
the lights and we slept late and [ __ ]
like that - yep so hopefully you guys
have a good Saturday and we'll talk to
again